all right ken has been begging me for
months to play with him and finally it's
your lucky day ken oh my god take me
back the nipples look like the top of
baby bottle my god
sexual jack all right it's my time my
time to shine here we go everybody you
like my face - what look at that that's
a sexy pose pointing for the stars dude
your shoulder your back muscles Ken my
god that's my face come on come on oh oh
Ken ha ha ha oh my god let's have a look
it's a Jackie boy Jack if you could not
swear that would be great I like your
Sun Tanning it looks great thank you I'm
an older gentleman your back looks like
an ass because it is no no no no no no
no no no don't worry I still got time I
say cut I'm a singer time no no [ __ ] you
should have 20 seconds damn it are you
telling me I have 15 I have 15 seconds
of fun you see Oh show actually no
I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine half a minute
I have half a minute get up there
[Laughter]
everybody oh you have a reserve okay
okay that's why yeah come on hands hey
what are you doing to your face Kane
climb I animate a face Ken oh hey there
Ken how you do it oh my god how do you
how do you do that you flexing Ken are
you flexing for the video ridiculous
[Music]
[Laughter]
that climbing this is serious
how do you guys do it seriously yeah
Viking power oh my god oh I shut your
why is it a goat or you got a problem
with goats now you got this come on look
at that there's like a few second delay
no no no there's no delay do it grunt oh
you're a new person each time
grab those pecs grab those nips my run
is ruined too recent finally a game with
a video game character I can relate to
[Laughter]
Jesus Ken what are you doing oh he said
made the reserve he's entering the
reserve Oh No you best climb faster
there boy
oh wow congratulations to Ken thanks
everybody I tried my best I want to put
on a master class are you ready the
master class with jacksepticeye I'll
show you how to climb men how to climb
jacksepticeye part one this is a seven
part series look at this [ __ ] go come on
come on hey you got me ready right what
I like so good at climbing men you tiny
little boys I bet you don't even drink
protein every single minute I'll show
you how it's done I inhale protein I am
protein you gotta you gotta get some
suspension for them [ __ ] you glide
effortlessly that's right from the first
of all I am stuck in myself come on
please two seconds ahhh represent your
country I give up you know what guys I'm
out of here
Peter's face don't give up it's solid
ass whatever I don't care yeah there you
go
go can go can use those pink nips I
don't want to be that guy cam but it
seems like there's a bit of a hue would
dis match between your face and your
body and nipples of course whoa don't
make fun of my whiteness I'm so sorry
are you holding a nip going outward
this is extreme titty fall that's pretty
good
okay here we go here we go oh damn
better with controls god damnit whoa
those mad foot here we go a [ __ ]
camera come on check please come on baby
there you go grab that try oh good no I
want to go higher enter the reserve is
in the reserve everybody come on kid
leave that podium you don't got it Ken
make that goat's proud can that booze
buy your own team come on you can still
do it Ken you can still do it
add some epic music you got this ken I'm
so disappointed but that's a dicker I
just I just can't do this
come on touch me just gay I'm gay that
he giving up wow I can't believe you
falling to the homophobes jebediah seize
the winner I'm so disappointed
mark Reed look what we made guys look
what we made
I want someone I want fan out of this
I'm good I'm good should we go back and
change our face really quick yeah I'm
almost dead all right do you guys are
going down this time here we go sweet
Jesus what are your feet see what I just
picked a random skin I just picked her
random one yeah yeah
oh wow so pretty well please don't make
fun of me okay stick that's right touch
that symbol Jack God like oh you're the
one worried about demagnetization the
most and then you pick a Soviet boy
what are you talking about I'm not the
one culturally appropriating like your
teeth I like that lip bite you got going
on how I feel while playing this game
the whole times like toast oh yeah come
on Xavier we can do this oh yeah oh yeah
you guys been working out no never
you just like this wow you're very good
can your clamps are good good can god
you're so buff here he comes
ah are you like where should I put this
ahead where should I put this hand
[Music]
Swedish massage everybody very good
your protein goes I'll show you guys the
perfect male specimen okay okay all
right sure where is he don't see him
anymore he's coming don't you worry
there's no way he can be come on come on
baby come on baby
Ireland Sweden be on top oh are you
kidding me are you kidding all you need
guys are pathetic this is how you climb
all right oh yeah show us green boy now
look who's [ __ ] green PewDiePie huh
don't swear oh my god what the hell
we're all here together beautiful we
should just start going horizontal no is
this how fort notice I never played it
it's just like building it for you
that's what I think
you just build a but no oh pinky boy
boys I thought that was [ __ ] Michael
from Vsauce on your face
oh my god it's climbing game or is it oh
I want someone to get the verticality in
their penis what was that again Jake
that's the scientific term Felix okay
yeah dudes not the goats not like this
fondling that God like a you guys are
reacting to stuff that's literally
happened like ages ago this is just a
secret YouTube meeting this is this is
fake history porn here Joseph Stalin
climbing the wall we go here we go yes
got a good [ __ ] system going now this
is too tall too intense damn it my thigh
boy Irish slinging fairy tale you weave
you don't know you're calling me a weeb
for not knowing [ __ ] words
you know what fairytale episode 300
what's wrong with you
[Laughter]
never getting a bit raises it's that a
new meme I never heard of that one
you and your [ __ ] memes deep swearing
jack and see what happens Leon how are
you doing this I'm gonna code
I'm gonna call YouTube on you boy oh my
god I got stuck on the dog the power of
react on his side it's the power of me
being good at games which I am no no no
grab grab something 25% gaming channel
PewDiePie here grab something grab
something
shut your pie Paul you Irish slug of
slime Irish silly
I'm family-friendly okay it's up to us
Calvin Calvin Zaza
there we go now oh no hate please
something gets me everything so Dutch
please don't do that please don't do
that to the view the coat has
representation you guys [ __ ] paints
3d match your friends I'm [ __ ] 40
right now Jack I need you to seriously
tone down this way you recorded a video
with an Irishman I'm gonna have to tell
you this is what happens this is what
happened the shade of your skin is
hurting my eyes
your voice is hurting my eyes that's
extremely insensitive Jack I can't
believe you said that
sorry I'm insensitive to pink people
look yeah well maybe next time you'll
think about pink people's feelings
[Music]
oh come on oh it's time it's time
young power levels this is the video on
YouTube right now
[Music]
you got one second oh my god I don't
even have the time in my time to get up
oh god okay here we go it's all my god
you've never seen can't do it no you you
Irish dumb ball go back in your example
slimy scum hey you take that back right
now
ah come on come on come on can show what
you got second choice Carrie - oh no
America is gonna you like that you
DeeDee teeing that goat Tioga baby this
is how you do it oh you look at though
he looks good well we have to give it to
the meatball wow wow what a tower all
right I look forward to see your tweet
boys